Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought
to you by a cent protein,
the cleanest least processed protein
I've ever consumed and I have tried just
about everything since well
before the four hour body.
I've started my day with
20 to 30 grams of protein.
First thing that has
been part of my routine,
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal.
So what to do.
Protein powders can be a fast way
to get this protein needs met,
but most products are full of crap.
They're bleached, they have excess sugar,
terrible artificial sweeteners or
just straightforward low grade,
low quality protein.
Ascent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent
company is actually a
cheese manufacturer so that they
produce their own native proteins.
It's,
it's really fascinating and I've looked
at they're processing it takes or it
took them about five years to develop.
You can mix the protein in as little as
four ounces without any clumps or issues
of mixed ability whatsoever.
And they nailed the taste.
They tested, for instance,
the chocolate version
282 different versions.
It put a lot of money and a lot of
time into r and D for this particular
product, and they have both
way and my seller casing.
So if you want to say improve body
composition and recovery overnight slow
release, you can take the my seller
casein or in my case, whey protein.
I would take postworkout for instance,
or in the morning. So check it out.
These guys were really fascinating.
Visit a scent protein.com
forward slash Tim, that's a s,
c e n t p r o t e,
I n.com a sense like
first ascent going up,
a scent protein.com forward slash Tim
and you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase.
If you want a very quick 20th 30 gram
dose to start your day or after workout.
This is a fantastic option. It is arguably
the best that I've found. So again,
chicken up a scent,
protein.com forward slash. Tim,
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for
blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for
everything every day. My site,
tim.blog is built on it. The websites
for my books, including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors. It's all
in wordpress.com and the
founder Matt Mullenweg,
one of my close friends has
appeared on the show many times.
Just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site, or both,
you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be
in good company. It's used
by the New Yorker, Jay Z,
Beyonce, five 38 tech crunch, Ted, CNN,
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google who shall remain
nameless,
has told me that wordpress.com offers the
best out of the box SEO imaginable and
quote,
and it's one of the many reasons that
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you
through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs
and templates that you can use,
and it's easy to get started. There's no
need to worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that there for 24
seven support, and they're very,
very responsive. If you have
questions, they get right back to you,
and this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least amount of.